you would think that a lot of this
discussion would be about the economy
about oil about the ruble how much of it
is well they did start the show with
some questions about economy and
inflation and then talked about the road
and foreign policy and then there were
people calling from far away city saying
they don't get salaries on time and
Putin was saying that he'll take care of
that right away yeah and there's also
one of the first questions sorry excuse
me on that one of the first questions
huh the first question was about food
inflation and woman was calling and
saying that last year she paid a certain
amount of money for her week's food
supply and now has to pay twice as much
like what's happening why federal
statistic has different numbers and put
in assured her that the band that Russia
imposed on certain imports after Europe
imposed sanctions on Russia that was a
conscious step so Russian agriculture
can expand and he mentioned that last
year gdp fell and manufacturing fell but
not agriculture so he said that that's
that was one of the steps so another
question was about economy and he said
that the rest on grounds for optimism so
he said the central the central bank
said the economy can contract as much as
the one percent but Putin said that now
we have maybe like some grounds for
optimism but people are not very fast to
believe him because last year he
promised that trouble will rebound but
trouble actually fell to the all-time
low this January so people are listening
and thinking then of course there was a
question about personal life you know he
divorced few years back and he said that
his ex-wife is happy and he's happy as
well good well that's important to have
an ex-wife that's havoc I know so Mike I
want to bring you in because you know a
lot about Russia you actually overall
think that investing rush is not a bad
idea well look I think investing in
Russia is not a bad idea in the sense
that things are cheap right and some of
their you know great companies like
spare bank you know bank was sixty-eight
percent market share we talked about the
problems with the banks here and not
making money spare bank makes a lot of
money
but there are some issues investing in
Russia yeah I mean usually something as
cheap as a reason right that's in this
case geopolitical risk the ruble is
falling doesn't look like it's going to
stop falling anytime soon the country is
in recession yeah well you know it's
interesting it's all again about
expectations so two years ago the
economy was in freefall and they did
what a lot of good countries do they
drop some bombs in a desert and that got
the economy to fall less this year and
it has showing signs of improvement so
it's that improvement on the margin
that's got people excited in the ruble
really has stabilized now it needs oil
to continue stabilizing but there are
some promising signs and when things are
as cheap as they are I mean some of the
cheapest stocks on the planet you have
to at least look around that sentiment
shift reflecting in the flows map here
we have G hashtag btv chart 937 in our
chart library you can see this is an ETF
and we saw outflows all the way until
just the beginning of this month really
I I was thinking that I saw some
analysts upgrades as well and I looked
back to the nodes Credit Suisse actually
advised investors to switch out of
Mexico and into Russia in a way they
raised their rating to a 25-percent
underweight so it's not an all-out bye
but you are seeing people starting to
get into it not clearly people believe
in what you're saying this morning my
question just to turn it round would be
okay they're cheap when was the last
time they were expensive ah it's a great
point and so its variations of cheap so
they're stupid cheap like they were at
the end of 98 or again it in 2009 and
today they're just cheap cheap but we
like Russia we like Russian equities
were a little bit overweight Russia we
run an emerging markets fund and we're a
little overweight Russia and one of my
favorite manager is actually from your
old home town in London prosperity
they're pounding the table right now on
increasing Russian exposure but mark
coming back to what Bonnie said about
geopolitical risk I mean there's a lot
of uncertainty just about the rule of
law I mean I've been following this on
top live the various questions which are
pretty amazing they asked about the
Panama papers but one of the things
asked what were these parliamentary
elections are coming up and his response
was on the record he's
it doesn't matter who votes it matter to
countable doesn't that really raise
questions about an investment in that
country he may have been poking fun at
us down in Florida four years ago not
just kidding but not look the rule of
law is simple in Russia right it's
Putin's law yet he has an eighty-five
percent approval rating and he has made
the majority of people's lives better if
you go back to where they were 10 12
years ago so look there there's
certainly geopolitical risks you and I
were talking before the show about the
planes buzzing the US destroyer out
right out Top Gun my favorite movie of
all time and that's real but that also
goes to national pride right the
Russians want to see that they are
flying their airplanes around and their
ships are sailing and they're feeling
strong and right now everything
economically i believe is about
confidence if you have confidence you're
confident as a country as a leader then
things are good and you look at world
leaders on the world stage who is more
confident in right now more effective
than Putin Mont usko sticking with us
Bloomberg zania Andrea Nova from Moscow
thank you very much for joining us I
know with several hours in it is still
going she's going to be busy today